when the shift changes of the Fiat
Chrysler plant in Melfi southern Italy
4000 people come and go within half an
hour not that long ago hardly anyone
came through here there was very little
work last two years were a disaster here
the new CEOs only recently started
making changes compared to this more
technology the work process and the
whole mentality have changed before amok
in a lament Alita one thing that hasn't
changed is Costantino Mena's quick
espresso before he starts an eight-hour
shift with very little to do the plant
for the past two years it's been a
financial struggle for him he was living
on short time unemployment benefits of
700 euros a month now he's glad to see
things picking up production has
increased enormously we used to build
about 340 cars a day on one line now
we're rolling more than 420 cars out per
day especially on the jeep line so it's
almost 100 cars more and that means lots
of new jobs have been created
56 year old motor mechanic Costantino
Menna has been working at Fiat for 23
years so he's used to night shift like
most of the workforce he lives not far
from the plant I'm on positions 10 and
11 on the line I'll be installing the
fuel tanks in jeeps for the next several
hours and to fixing the rear cross
braces for the bumpers
cameras are not allowed into the plant
and success or no the management is not
giving interviews some 1500 new workers
have been hired the Fiat 500x and Jeep
renegade models are selling especially
well in South America melfi's old town
traditionally this region has been among
Italy's poorest the Fiat plant changed
that the wheat euro has made European
produced cars cheaper outside the EU and
given the export market of boost Fiat
Chrysler has made production more
cost-efficient by outsourcing the German
supplier browser for example has a
facility right next to the plant in
Melfi browser specializes in car doors
it can deliver within just four hours of
receiving an order many competitors have
been producing this way for years now
Fiat Chrysler is following suit at the
moment the feeling that also for the
next months it's really that we will
have a very big change of this trend of
economy in in Italy because of course
automotive is in Italy and important
industries so these new activities will
support the world economy in Italy
Costantino Mena's shift ends at 6:00 in
the morning his wife has already started
on hers his ten year old daughters still
sleeping costantino will earn over two
thousand euros gross this month money
earned with hard work and long hours six
days a week and lots of night shifts and
overtime loss got a little buggering
that's the price we pay when they bring
out a new model exactly cuando C it's
like a boom we just roll up our sleeves
and work even harder we suddenly had him
look less traumatic
before he goes to bed for the day he has
to take the dog out and bring his
daughter to school the new Fiat Chrysler
models spelled jobs and a future for the
people of Melfi now it's up to the
Italian American automaker to make sure
their products remain in demand on the
global market